this is not good news and it could
slow down those really great vaccination
numbers that i just told you about
u.s regulators are now calling for a
complete and total pause
on using the johnson johnson coronavirus
vaccine
because of six blood clot cases
that have happened among six million
people who have received
the johnson johnson vaccine so the first
piece is that the fda and the cdc
have already decided they will no longer
use the vaccine at
federal vaccination sites they are
urging states
to also pause and as far as i know
basically every state is doing it i know
people who were scheduled to get their j
j
shot today their appointment has been
canceled what we know so far
per the new york times is that six
recipients
in the u.s developed a really rare
disorder that involves
blood clots within about two weeks of
vaccination
it's six people all women between the
ages of 18
and 48. uh one woman
died a second woman in nebraska has been
hospitalized and is in critical
condition
nearly it's actually not six it's nearly
seven million people
in the u.s have received the jnj shot
so far nine million more doses have been
shipped to states which presumably will
just be held for the time being
dr peter marks who directs the fda's
center for biologics evaluation and
research put out a statement along with
uh the principal deputy director of the
cdc ann
shoeshot and they said quote we are
recommending a pause in the use of the
vaccine out of an abundance of caution
so let's talk the numbers through six
incidents out of about
seven million vaccinations the first
question is
was this caused by the vaccine or did
these six
individuals have some underlying
disorder or abnormality that was
exacerbated
by the vaccine other questions that are
being looked at
include given that we're talking about
all six of the individuals
were women aged 18 to 48 could this be
connected to some kind of medication
for example and this is just an example
there's no evidence of this but this is
the type of question that's being asked
if all six of these women were on oral
contraceptives the birth control pill
that would be something to look at we
just don't know yet and while it's been
while it's being investigated it's going
to be a setback in the vaccination
program
everybody is being clear right now that
there is not a causal relationship
here but it has to be investigated in
the u.s somewhere between 300 000 and
600 000 people
per year develop blood clots generally
but not this particular kind of blood
clot this is a cerebral venous
sinus thrombosis it's very very rare and
we have to do it safely that has to be
priority number one
we also have to make sure that this is
reported on in a responsible way you
know what's going to be on fox news
tonight
the anti-vaxxers are already saying see
we were right about all of it
well no you the same people said
mrna vaccines are really really
dangerous
and it actually it's been the two
adenovirus vaccines
that we are seeing this blood clot issue
with the jnj vaccine here in the u.s
astrazeneca in europe and in other
places remember that
out of 34 million people who received
the astrazeneca vaccine in britain
as well as the eu and three other
countries there were
222 of uh these blood clot
incidents linked with a low platelet
level so a slightly different situation
um it's it's been the adenovirus
vaccines where we've seen this
not the mrna and so when the same people
that were talking about mrna come
forward and say all of these vaccines
are unsafe
let's let's not allow them to uh to gesh
gallop us
let's talk now about the effect on just
the vaccination program in the united
states
with the jnj doses we were expecting to
have enough
for all 260 million
adults in the u.s by the end of next
month by the end of may didn't mean
everybody would have received their
shots by then but there would be enough
supply without the johnson and johnson
doses
most adults there would be enough supply
for 230 million adults that's not
everybody that's not all 260 million
but so many people are refusing to get
the vaccine
that in practice even without the jnj
doses
there very well could still be enough
doses for every adult
who wants the vaccine to get one
um and that supply would be available by
the end of may so
we could be depending on how many people
want the vaccine this could be a delay
of a few weeks in getting to where we
hope to get
it could be a delay of a couple of
months there are other countries
that are so dependent on future doses of
the jnj vaccine
that if this doesn't get resolved in a
way that it's deemed to be safe
and the jnj vaccination continues it
could really be a disaster for
the plans of of some other countries
um the vaccine might also come back
online relatively quickly but with some
demographic restrictions if we can
determine that there's something about
why
it's only affected six women
do you say well we're bringing it back
online but only men should get the jnj
vaccine
this is idle speculation but these are
the things medical regulators are going
to be looking at
so not the news that we wanted
we continue vaccinating with the pfizer
and the modern vaccines
deaths are continuing down cases are
level
and if we can race the variance
successfully
cases should be significantly lower in
about a month
and we will continue following what
happens with the jnj vaccine as well as
others distribution
cases variants and all of that let me
know your thoughts
if you've received the jnj vaccine
already but you're within the two-week
period during which these reactions are
happening are you worried
uh or are are the numbers so low that
it doesn't concern you let me know i'm
on twitter at deepakman
many so-called healthy snacks
don't taste that great they don't fill
you up they don't satisfy a craving
which is why you should check out our
sponsor
monk pack and their keto nut and seed
bars
delicious sweet snacks with only a gram
of sugar or less
two to three grams of net carbs and just
150 calories perfect for the
keto or low carb diet or anybody who
just generally tries to eat
a low sugar diet like me i love the monk
pack keto nut and seed bars
just a great balance of sweet and salty
soft and chewy but with a nice
crunch from the nuts and seeds you can
get
great flavors like caramel not caramel
come on guys
caramel sea salt sea salt dark chocolate
peanut butter dark chocolate that's my
personal favorite they'll give you
all of your money back if you don't love
it go to monkpack.com the link is down
below and you'll get twenty percent off
any of their products
when you use the coupon code pacman